hey we hit 60k followers thanks everyone
yeah thanks again gotham chess you rated
at a very intense moment
uh but yeah everyone should check out
gotham chess i'll add you to this
follower extension
awesome chess okay i'll play london
i have to go at least for the first few
games i'm going to stay in my comfort
zone
when it comes to the opening
var is a demon yeah he's good at chess
oh let's play this move this is also
kind of new
london theory um
yeah queen f3 is like it's kind of
becoming more trendy recently
but even strong players don't entirely
know about it
uh the idea is to make black commit to
this or this
now i'm gonna go for the the king side
attack
if i if i win one game against var i'll
be happy
he's the type of player who can probably
like beat me 10 in a row
but okay the first game is it's a sign
we're going to have some fights
wow it's orion arrow gifting subs thanks
so much
oh ryan arrow gifting subs to cabbage
64 and a cabana if
four six and yash numbers
really appreciate that play a3 here
the problem is takes takes c4 is kind of
c4i can take it
we can't play c4
yeah i'll play a3
oh there's a dog outside the window
that's barking i don't have people here
though
i've tried to fix my mic so it's not
having so much background noise
anyway okay we should focus on the chest
i have a time advantage at some nice
kind of
opening exotic opening preparation i
think i have to take this
i'll go for queen g3 with a battery
going for actually i don't know what the
threat is
like sometimes there's a threat of
taking but
i'm probably not in this position i'll
go for 92
i'll probably castle and then still try
and attack on the king side
bishop a6 is a really probably really
strong move
i could play f3
i could play this move too and attempt
to win a pawn but
probably not a wise decision there's
rook d1 with a
x-ray i'll play rook t1
i might be forced to bond cloud against
my will if he takes on you two
but that's part of life also thanks waya
pl subbing with prime
appreciate that
hmm that's interesting
i want to take with rook but then my
pawns are in shambles
i could take with pawn
it's a weird decision
you could take with knight as well
just worried about the c file
i'm trying to anticipate after rook
takes
d4 there's queen c8 i guess
and then
let's stick with let's be active i'm
gonna prioritize piece activity over
pawn structure maybe now f3
um that's difficult though so bishop
wants to take my knight and the queen
wants to take the pawn
c4 doesn't really help
oh what to do
queen g2 maybe
it's actually kind of a neat idea queen
g2
so the idea is after it takes takes
takes i take and i
defend and attack and if knight c6 and i
fork with a rook
the queen would help still defend an
attack
if he sees all of that he chooses not to
go for it
so i can take the pawn though
now my time maybe f3
this is so ugly but f3 at least it
defends my knight that prepares castling
like castling rook f2 and i can turtle
up
but my pieces are so ugly
no offense to my pieces like rook d2
rook f2
like the rook doesn't belong in e4 my
queen doesn't belong on g2
at least oh there's this move in this
move
my time
i mean rook d4 is probably the most
logical
i'm up a pawn that's like the one good
thing about the situation
probably not for long though
okay if takes and i can maybe fix the
structure
but that's not happening my other pawn
i can't save everything here if you take
with rook
or knight let's play with knight to keep
pieces on the board expecting queen
takes c3
perhaps bishop e no bishop there doesn't
work let's go for this move
to go for the storm the defense
[Music]
of takes i play this
and he's such a beast of blitz
there goes my bishop any hope
good game well played i i have the auto
elite chest message
a game i lose it we'll send this message
ah okay lost two that was a cool game
though
i mean i was kind of happy with the
opening until my king got stuck
bishop a6 was really like it's a really
key move for him
let's look at the next game yeah i was
curious of like
how well you knew some of these openings
i was trying to play some uh some novel
things
i knew i i i knew some of the
the you know because i know you know a
lot of this tricky opening so
the the this next game we played i think
this is the game where you played queen
f3 line right
uh yes yeah the queen of three yeah this
was actually played by my student
against me
oh and and he might have seen it from
your streams my one of my new students
are frankel our franco uh interesting
yeah so uh so he played against me this
and uh and first i didn't know anything
about it then i looked at it
and i realized that there was there were
games played in this with shimanov and
a few other grand masters yeah it's it
gained popularity i think towards the
end of last year
yeah and it's it's both like leela and
stockfish approved like leela will will
have queen effie as the top move and
then suggest these lines with knight c3
and g4
h4 yeah so yeah yeah my friend uh who is
watching
and uh and he confirmed that he saw this
idea from your stream
oh okay yeah so he might be a follower
or a subscriber too
yeah queen f3 uh so i think i have to
play d5
so there's two moves there's d5 and
there's knight c6
and yeah if i ever play this in bullets
sometimes people will pre-move bishop
b7 so it's an added bonus it works great
yeah
so here the d5 looks fine yeah
yeah and now g4
so where where somehow it went really
really nice for me where do you think
you might have slept
you might have slipped a little bit here
you think maybe you should play knight
g2 sometime
or yeah no i i think like once i get
these double pawns
and especially like once you play bishop
a6 on move 12
i i was in trouble yeah yeah no i think
when i when i was watching these games
my impression was they they wait they
wait actually they don't put a bishop on
it today
right because maybe bishop here and here
yeah and they very quickly they go along
castle actually the point i think to get
the g5
you got to get the pawn on g5 very
quickly i think
that makes sense right before the start
but before the structure on c3 is
compromised so i think it
get into g5 quickly but can you play 94
here
because i don't know if i want to castle
queen side allow the double pawns this
this this is a problem yeah because
i might still be able to take but
i'm wondering if maybe i should just
delay
[Music]
wonder if there's a way to maybe first
play 92
i think i think yeah maybe they do that
maybe that's why they maybe
or even first castle queen side i don't
know or castle queen side because then
bishop before so if you play bishop b4
then i don't have to commit to g4 i can
play 92 and a3
exactly yeah i think maybe that's how
they play i
i actually look at this recently there
was two games by shimanov and they were
it was there was another russian grand
master a strong player
he had couple of games as well that he
won i see one game from moy cinco
in 2017 actually sure sure
absolutely well of course there's been
more games played online uh
as well so yeah
yeah but yeah i felt uh
i mean i felt like i was kind of
surviving
yeah even after bishop a6 yeah you you
defended it very well i think because it
looked
it looked really bad but you this i
never fully got out of trouble
yeah you managed to castle only last one
pawn you know but maybe at some point
you could have taken on d4
maybe that was a better chance i don't
know later on
uh yeah it's still kind of awkward yeah
it's uh yeah the pieces were not uh
harmonizing that well
yeah the coordination was broken and it
was very hard to
and the problem was very hard to start
an attack or do something to get some
kind of contra play so yeah
uh i think i think probably yeah the
conclusion for this line guys if you
want to play
you should try to do this idea early
uh you know early long castle i think
i like this yeah and then so
you you don't have to worry about
getting the double pawns because this
i think this is fine and then quickly
you get the g4 g5 in
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah this
is another line like i just
haven't had so much experience with like
the move order nuances
because it's it's hard to like it it's
not every every
game you can get it so consistently
um but it's that's why it's it's great
to have matches like this where like
you're really challenging
some of the ideas early in the opening
and uh sure you can learn a lot from
move order yeah you also surprised me in
that one more game but we'll get to that
game as well i think it was the french
game
yeah the ortho schnapp